hello in this video we'll talk about the
principles behind acid fast staining
acid fast staining is a differential
staining method used in microbiology
the stain is used to identify acid-fast
organisms such as
that of indigenous mycobacterium
in this staining the acid first bacteria
would appear reddish whereas the
non-acid-fast bacteria would appear blue
in this video it would be totally clear
what is the basis of this differential
coloring but let's understand what are
the acid fast organisms
acid fast organisms are characterized by
the presence of
wax-like nearly impermeable cell wall
they have very high level of mycolic
acid large amount of fatty acids waxes
and complex lipid which make their cell
wall literally impermeable to all the
substances
so their cell wall is so much resistant
that they don't take up any other stains
such as gram stain
and acid first organisms are highly
resistant to disinfectants or dry
conditions
and we need to do
this kind of acid for staining to
identify mycobacterium tuberculosis and
that's why this is really important from
a clinical perspective as well so let's
hit the virtual lab and try to do a acid
first training
first of all let's get introduced with
the reagents
we need
carbolfuse gene as the primary stain
then methylene blue as the counter stain
there would be acid alcohol which would
be the decolorizing agent there would be
a distilled water for washing purposes
and some other reagents like pipette
forceps all of these things would be
very common to any microbiol lab
so first step involves smearing the
sample on a slide here the patient
derived sample would be smeared on a
particular slide and we are expecting
that this particular sample might have
mycobacterium
tuberculosis in that at the end of this
video we would understand whether it has
it or not
so the primary stain would involve
carbol fusion carpal fusion is actually
a particular stain which has phenol in
it and it can really penetrate even
this impermeable
mycolic acid containing cell wall so
they would penetrate and get inside
the cell wall
carbon fusing actually has basic fusion
ethanol
then phenol i mean the melt heat metal
melted crystals of phenol and also
distilled water
so all the bacteria at this particular
step would be colored red
with the carbol fusion
be it acid fast or be it non-acid fast
and this incubation would happen for
let's say 30 seconds
after this step there is a heat fixation
step which would fix the stain even
further and it's kind of important such
that these bacteria should adhere to the
slide and should not wash away when we
are
adding other reagents
now in the step three we would be using
a decolorization agent
after applying this decolorization agent
the bacteria which are non-acid fast
cannot retain this carbol fusion stain
this decolorization agent is very strong
and this decolorizing agent contains
ethanol and hydrochloric acid so it
would wipe out all the staining from the
non-acid-first organisms
remember the acid-first bacteria has
very rigid impermeable cell wall so
actually this decolorizing agent cannot
wipe out the stain from these acid fast
bacteria so by the end of this step the
acid first bacteria should
retain their red staining whereas the
non acid fast bacteria would fail to
retain their carbol fusion stain
now in the last step we would be doing
counter staining with a counter stain
popularly used known as methylene blue
it's a blue colored counter stain so
obviously
the
bacteria which has
failed to retain carbol 15
now would take the counter stain
methylene blue remember this acid-first
bacteria has very impermeable cell wall
so they would not allow methylene glue
to stem them
so acid-first bacteria would retain
their red coloration due to carbol
fusion
and the non-acid fast bacteria would
ultimately take the countest in
methylene blue and thereby they would be
they would be visualized as blue cells
so there are two methods used in the
microbiology lab one is xyle nielsen
method and another is kinyon method both
these methods are useful for
microbiologists
and you can take a look at the reagents
really quickly
but i'm not going to get into details of
these exact protocols
now as per summary we have used a
primary stain carbol fusion which is
highly permeable it can even penetrate
the almost impermeable cell walls of
acid fast bacterium
now
after that we have used a strong
decolorizing agent such as acid alcohol
which would wipe out all the stain from
non-acid fast bacteria and we have
counter stain with methylene blue where
the non acid fast bacteria took a blue
stain
and the acid first bacteria has retained
their red curbal fusion stain
this video tells us what is
the basis of acid fasting and how it is
really important for medical
microbiologist
you can get all the notes and flashcards
in my facebook page the link is provided
in the description you can click on the
link and don't forget to like that page
as well
as usual don't forget to like share and
subscribe you can support my channel on
patreon if you are an indian viewer you
can support me via the veeam upi app my
courses are also present in india's
largest online platform on academy you
can use ap 10 to get a 10 discount as
well
if you wish to connect to me in social
media i'm there in twitter instagram
facebook and linkedin all the social
media links are provided in the
description thank you see you in the
next video